I had I had three big ideas in in one
year and one of which I'm patenting
right now i'll share with you the one
that is in the process of being patented
the the big idea number one was that
empathy was actually the the source of
innovation big i needed number two was
about actually coming up with an
innovation dashboard to actually help
companies play to their strengths by
focusing on what they did well and not
on stuff that they didn't do well big
idea number three was the pug dog that
the pug dog was i looked at the world
and i thought you know there's no really
great ways to entertain my daughter and
there's you can make a dog like this but
that doesn't really look like a dog and
they can make a dog that looks like this
but that's kind of two-dimensional and
yulia has only one year and i looked
around and there's no great ways to make
a hand sign which looks like a dog so I
came up with one and that's what i call
the pug dog and the way you have a pug
dog is you make a fist right and then
you lift up two sides to 80 years and
you drop down the tongue and that's the
pug dog patent pending